so you co-wrote the screenplay and you
also co-directed the film how does that
collaboration work especially when it
comes to to code directors like what if
somebody like says no I don't want to do
it that way and you go yeah I want to do
it that way well we we usually come to
set as directors we've worked things out
before we get set so we've talked
through the shots and what we're how
we're going to approach different scenes
for the week and I would say if either
of us have a super strong feeling about
something
the other one will give I mean we don't
usually have
opposite incredibly strong feeling one
of us might say I would like to shoot it
this way but they don't say no I really
really really really I think that's sort
of the the we didn't make a contract for
this but this is how it has worked out
yeah I mean it's you know we get answer
that question a lot I think there's a
lot of curiosity about how co-directors
work how we're married that's another
issue
um the um but you know we really have a
unified Vision almost always and it's
you know as you've got you know if I was
in my 20s and I wanted to do something I
wouldn't back down and I
take my heels in and later I'd say why
was I fighting about that I didn't even
make sense to me what I was fighting for
but now I could I can hear we kind of go
in both ways which is if I say something
that makes no sense Maya says that makes
no sense and I could say oh yeah you're
right that doesn't make any sense and it
forces you to articulate your reason for
why you want to do the scene in a
certain way um which is really helpful
because that obviously expect that that
is something that will affect the entire
everyone everyone you'll be able to
articulate that for everyone which is
really important
um so yeah I also say it's a good
question it's a it's a you know
filmmaking is collaborative you're just
endlessly getting ideas from every
different department and so we see
ourselves as part of that big entity
that you know moves together so so where
did you make this movie how did you find
this place how do I get there I I just
want to like move there right now
foreign
so we ended up so we so the movie uh
takes place in Massachusetts
um but we shot it in Nova Scotia
um and we had I mean Nova Scotia is very
very pretty it was this little town
called Chester in Nova Scotia that I
guess has a lot of people from New
England it was it was challenging
because I'm I'm from Massachusetts and
um to get it to look really like
um Marblehead or one of the one of the
North Shore towns
um was there's not a lot of the same
architecture or anything in up in Nova
Scotia but uh Chester was settled by
people from New England who had vacation
houses there and so uh we were able to
Cobble together a New England feeling
and it was beautiful I mean we shot from
September to into November which is a
beautiful time of year
um we were very happy that to be
shooting in the fall it seemed like the
right
season for this film
um and yeah
so you shot it from uh September into
November of 2020. no oh of 19. oh lucky
so this could be this movie has a beard
longer than mine it's so old
so yeah that must have been a relief
that you got it done before all that yes
yes um but also Morena backerman is also
wonderful in the film you know a role
that we don't really get to see her yeah
uh you know do very often and her
Dynamic with with Sigourney offices is
extremely different obviously from
Kevin's but they're they also are
terrific together and Sigourney um was
really she was very clear on what what
she was looking for with Rebecca which
was you know just this warmth and an
escape from the sort of rigidity of the
community the New England community that
Hildy lives in so someone from outside
who brought just a just a more
free a Freer feeling and she needed you
know she was really she was very
cognizant of the fact that she needed a
friend a new friend from outside the
world that she'd been in and Marina just
felt
just brought that energy to it which was
and they and they had a great time
together they also yeah I mean the nice
thing about Sigourney also as being the
sort of at the top of your of of your
cast he sees she brings a wonderful
energy and expectation that everyone is
gonna
be there to you know work hard together
and not get you know not cause a lot of
problems with each other I mean she just
brought a really professional but warm
vibe to the whole set you know with all
the films that you've directed together
but especially the films that you've
written together what were the unique
writing challenges and what were the
unique directing challenges for the good
house
hmm well I mean certainly the voice for
writing the script the voice was so
important to us and so to really be able
to capture that voice and we're thinking
a lot also about our mothers and what
they have experienced and so we wanted
to make it you know a tribute to these
women who work really hard and feel like
they get left behind in some ways so
that was I think the number one
challenge for us as writers but I think
but and and then there's a lot of great
lines in the book we wanted to be able
to uh bring those into the movie and
again I think when we when we we start
started out sort of like there was a lot
of voice over in the movie I mean it was
most it was tons of VoiceOver because
all this all the stuff to camera in the
beginning it was a voiceover
um and then we realized
I mean it will be a much more
interesting
Dynamic for her to actually be speaking
to the audience like they're like the
friend so I I'd say that click that
would and and Sigourney had not done
that before
and in the beginning she was like this
is so strange but by the end she was
always like where's my friends this is
like you know the camera she wants to
find the camera and tell the camera what
what's really going on you know so she
really got into it got into it
um but I would say that as a writer that
was the hardest and then anytime you're
doing a book you're trying to be
faithful to the book but you have to
compress so much and cut so much stuff
out of the book uh so it's all that's
always a bit of a challenge you know one
of the other things that I really felt
made the film really authentic and
genuine is and and having Hildy break
that fourth wall she's talking to you
like like you're you're in the room
you're part of the crowd here so
and you brought up like you yeah I you
know I had a drink and I'm good you know
but the person you're with has another
and they're they're good and then they
have the third and there's a lot in the
film and paraphrasing like oh that's the
third drink and your personality changes
but through that and as if the
progression gets worse you still are on
healthy side you're rooting for her so
what were the challenges for Sigourney
to keep you on her side like what was
the prep that she did to really nail
that side of her character
I mean I I you know the
it's kind of a tricky question because
you know she's I I I can't speak for
what she's doing I mean I could see I
could see what she's doing which is that
she's comes to rehearsal very prepared
and ready not rigid but with very sad
ideas about what about this character
and she does what I think all actors
should do which is whatever the part
fall in love with this character and
really embody it so that kind of answers
for that's as best as I think I could
answer that specific question I think
she just tried and just tried to play it
really authentically
as a person who believed that he'll who
was on as as Hildy thinking that Hildy
doesn't have a problem and that was so
important
um because to bring that denial to the
her performance
um
yeah you know we don't think about you
know we could ask the tone question a
lot and you know I think 30 years ago
this was not like what what's the tone
of Terms of Endearment you just went and
saw it and you went like that's a really
interesting movie that has funny parts
and dramatic parts or Kramer versus
Kramer or Ordinary People these were
just very normal movies that kind of
have disappeared from the American
landscape so for for us we don't we
every every scene is its own moment and
this scene could be funny it makes sense
for it to be funny this is more dramatic
we play for the we go for the drama you
know it's not it we just kind of look at
each individual moment and try and
capture that moment and I do try to I
mean I think we do try not to worry too
much about
I mean well obviously we want the
audience to be on hildy's side but sort
of trusting that you we all know I mean
one of the reasons we decided to break
the fourth wall was we thought everybody
knows Sigourney Weaver you know we all
know Sigourney Weaver so when she turns
and talks to us that's going to have
impact
um uh and so that was very important and
I think we sort of just trusted that if
she was talking to us she's funny and
and she can be you know healthy
certainly can be Brusque and cold
sometimes and Yankee but people will
like her you know and will want and see
you know anyway we'd sort of trusted
that people would be on her side you
brought up Kramer versus Kramer you
brought up Terms of Endearment this
movie definitely has that feel uh and
it's a lost art we haven't had a movie
that felt like those films in a long
long time you also brought up the Lost
weekend and at the same time you were
talking about that I was thinking of
Days of Wine and Roses a little more
recently Robert zemeckis is the flight
uh with Denzel Washington you know
movies I'm really like lean heavily into
it but again because because of the
progression that so many of us
experience where we're like oh they just
like to have fun oh maybe they like to
drink a little too much in that nope
they got a problem it just felt much
much more genuine that way so what was
the what's the takeaway that you hope
people get from the film and what kind
of reactions did you get from people who
went like yeah I've experienced that
well I mean just what you're describing
really we certainly over the last
however many months it's been around
a lot of people have come up to us at
different times to say I've had this
very similar experience this is my story
this kind of thing and you know we're
not trying to make a PSA we're trying to
make it some entertainment we want it to
be good and entertaining but we also
wanted to be about something so
um you know and I again I credit the
book for really setting the template for
us
well I want to thank everyone for being
here for today's screening of the good
house thank you Maya thank you Wally and
enjoy the rest of your week and thank
you so much